what you need to know this thursday
morning begins in dallas where the
cowboys
officially sort of have one of their new
defensive weapons in the fold aldon
smith who has been out of football since
2015 when he was suspended for a minimum
of a year but unable to effect
reinstatement after that conditionally
reinstated by the national football
league he has had multiple violations
arrests he's had positive tests he's had
off-field incidents galore and now he's
getting a chance at the age of 30 he
turns 31 later this year to come back
and be a difference maker for the dallas
cowboys a lot of people are still
confused about why he wasn't back sooner
because of the new substance abuse
policy
that eliminates suspensions for positive
tests the problem is for anyone who was
already in that suspended status that
indefinite suspension where you're out
for a minimum of a year and there are
plenty of great players who are in that
category
nothing changed you didn't get amnesty
you didn't get a reset to zero you
didn't get a clean slate you still had
to get your reinstatement through the
old system and nobody really knew what
the nfl was going to do by way of
reinstatement in a new substance abuse
policy because the commissioner has full
discretion with no deadline as to when
he has to make a decision it was the
same as it always was so this may be an
indication chris that for some of these
guys that are still floating around out
there whether it's
randy gregory whether it's josh gordon
whether it's martavius bryant maybe
there's gonna be a pathway back into the
nfl but for alton smith the path is
there he has an opportunity but we've
talked about this before when he landed
with the cowboys guy hasn't played in
more than four calendar years what can
we reasonably expect from him
yeah i mean i think that's the big
question i mean a star i mean a big time
star before
all the off the field issues and
everything started to pile up to where
yeah he's missed a lot of time i don't
know what we can expect to him i don't
have high hopes and i don't say that to
be disrespectful to aldon smith or
anything like that you know and again
i'm not going to sit here and try to
tell you i'm the specimen or athlete
that alden smith is but i can speak to
my experience of being outside of the
nfl or being in the nfl but unable to
play for a long period of time and when
i got first thrown back into the fire
i'm only playing quarterback too that's
a little different than having to play
defense to end and be strong and
explosive you know i felt like the game
was moving a million miles per hour it
was like it was like the first time i
played football ever again it is a tough
adjustment it really is let alone that's
just practice a game and you get into
mid-season form and things that's a
whole nother level of intensity and
scrutiny and paying attention to details
of technique and all those things so
really i almost look at it like this
mike if he makes the team
i i think that is a win period i'm not
so sure he makes the team but but if he
does i go wow that's an unbelievable
feat for a guy that's been out of
football for this long
and the other thing to remember under
this new substance abuse policy even
though no players will be suspended for
positive tests for players who were
indefinitely suspended and now get
reinstated any violation opens the door
to another indefinite suspension we'll
see how the nfl handles it there had
been a trend in recent years chris where
and the nfl didn't publicize this they
didn't broadcast it i think when the
ratings dropped in 2016 and then again
in 2017 the nfl realized should we
really be going out of our way to try to
keep great young players off the field
because of marijuana or some other
non-ped that they may be using and i
sense they were working with guys that
otherwise could have been thrown back
out after a reinstatement it's supposed
to be a very very fine line once you're
back in one false move and you're back
out i've sensed that guys like josh
gordon have gotten extra consideration
so we'll see and look we're not supposed
to know about any of the violations any
of the stuff that goes on beyond the
behind the curtain but but that stuff
tends to get out sometimes we'll see
what kind of lenience or not the nfl
will apply to a guy like aldon smith now
that he's back in but here's hoping that
if he fails it's not because
of our field issues it's if he just
can't do it because five years have
passed and he's going to be 31 and the
game is too fast and the game has passed
him by so be it but i hope he gets a
chance to stand or fall on his own merit
physically not anything else yeah i
agree and you know what mike you know
you you've hit a lot of good stuff on
this you know the the substance abuse
policy how it's changed i mean i agree
with a lot of what you said and then we
know what at face value when i first saw
you know the new rules i thought well
that's bullcrap why shouldn't alden
smith and josh gordon just be able to
walk right back into the league to play
but you know as a human and as you sit
there to think about it you know the nfl
they're doing the right thing here they
are and even though the rules have
changed you know we we don't want to
just like you know open the floodgates
for guys that have had real real issues
and demons dealing with substance abuse
issues we don't i mean we don't want to
be like oh hey we changed our rules we
know you've had issues hey come right in
and here you go you can ruin your life
again like a kid in this candy store
just start taking drugs and going crazy
no
you know it this is a bigger thing than
just a football player too these are
humans who are trying to straighten out
their life so i do think the nfl's doing
the right thing here by these certain
cases of not just saying hey the rules
of change come back in and play and do
whatever you got to do off the field we
don't care anymore
these are the cases i think that we'll
see going forward when you see guys
getting arrested or getting pulled over
and having drugs in their car there is
going to be some
you know they're going to be putting the
drug policy for that type of stuff so i
understand them doing it with guys like
aldon smith and josh gordon is what i'm
saying
now alton smith
was suspended most recently after an
arrest for dui
for hit and run
and so it's got a different element than
just positive marijuana tests with randy
gregory the cowboys defensive end who
remains on suspended status there isn't
that same off-field stigma that that
goes above and beyond violations of the
policy via positive tests or failure to
appear to a test or diluted sample
whatever it is that falls under that
category of of a positive test his agent
peter schaefer gave a quote to shireen
williams last night on gregory's status
said schaefer we're working through the
process we're very happy for alden and
we wish him all the luck in the world
and successful resumption of a career
it's refreshing to see the nfl following
through on their stated goal to focus
more on rehabbing players than punishing
players so right
look and and that's randy gregory is the
next test you know some people out there
think gregory's not getting back in well
i look at i say if walden smith's back
in then gregory should get back in they
all should get they should find a way to
give all these guys a clean slate even
though they're not going to get a clean
slate when they're back we've already
established that they're going to be
subject in theory to another suspension
for one false move unlike every other
player but at least give them a chance
to come back in this new climate give
them an opportunity to continue their
careers and earn money and i understand
at the end of the day there's only 53
guys on a roster it's a meritocracy and
every guy who gets a second chance is
taking away someone else's first chance
if this guy is better if he's more
worthy and more deserving of a roster
spot give him that opportunity i don't
even want to use it in terms of second
chance because i'm not a big believer
especially if we're only talking about
violations of the substance abuse policy
where guys are on their own time in the
off season and they're still subject to
testing testing testing testing for
things that shouldn't matter to the
national football league things are
illegal in a bunch of the states where
the nfl now does business why the hell
does the nfl even care about this some
should some say it should be gone all
together that it's their their business
and and you know what if they're high
all the time and they can't get their
job done then they're subject to getting
cut because they're not good enough but
right i mean look to the extent that
some of these guys are chronically under
the influence of marijuana and there's
still bad asses on the field more power
to them if they're pulling it off so
yeah this isn't something the nfl is
doing for safety reasons it's not being
done for competitive reasons it's not
being done for any reason other than
years ago the nfl decided we need to
create this example for all the kids out
there because of the war on drugs and
they've kept it ever since and hopefully
one of these days chris they'll just get
rid of it all together yeah well mike
you know i'm with you there in that
fight there's no doubt about that and
you know with randy gregory
you know it i am and listen mike to say
the further off of something else you
said i i had teammates you know i have
never ever been like that even with my
smoking i am an end of the day you know
end of the week type smoker it's my
reward for working hard or whatever it
may be but i had teammates who hey yeah
they smoked before they came to work in
the morning for prac you know before
practice might have even smoked a little
at lunch time during while we're at the
facility and doing all that and i can
really sit here at a test and say they
were better off like that than being
like on edge crazy nor you know crazy
energy and just mad and angry like there
were some guys that were better off like
that i'm not saying that's for everybody
and i'm not sitting out here trying to
like say hey that's the right way to
live i'm not i'm just saying for some
people it works with randy gregory first
off i do give him more of a fighting
chance than aldon smith as far as being
successful and playing in the league you
know yeah he's missed what 2017 and 2019
right so he's played three of the last
five years
that's not as big of a gap uh as far as
alden smith's concerned and then mike to
what you said too if all dismissal out
in randy gregory certainly should be
allowed in you know none of his stuff
has you know led to off the field you
know arrests and things like that with
the law or anything like that it's been
purely marijuana and i've been around
randy gregory a little bit he is as nice
as they come and i think that's why
dallas has been so loyal to him jason
garrett was loyal to him i think the
jones family the same reason this kid's
got a lot of good in his heart he really
does you could see it when i was around
him i knew it within the first five
minutes i was talking to him so i of
course would love to see it this is the
perfect guy you want to see get that
second chance or continue to tr further
along his career you know and let alone
hey the other thing i'll say too the
cowboys they need one of these two guys
to kind of come through they're a little
short of the defensive end area so it
would be nice if one of them could make
the team and actually contribute
the topic came up the other day when we
were looking at potential upgrades for
various teams and for most teams it was
a one-on-one comparison for the cowboys
multiple guys out multiple guys in and
also new defensive coordinator mike
nolan taking over for rod marinelli but
you've got right smith in this group
that includes gerald mccoy and ontario
poe replacing michael bennett malik
collins and robert quinn they need alden
smith to step up they need him to be not
quite the guy that he was back in 2011
he was a seventh overall pick taking
four spots before no three or four spots
before jj watt i think it was four j.j
watt was 11 to the texans alton smith
was seven to the 49ers he was averaging
chris nearly one sack per game for like
two seasons before his career was
derailed that is incredible
it's incredible
you know mike i i classify aldon smith
as one of those guys where the first
time you see him in person it was like
the julius peppers effect to me i just
went
damn i just didn't realize he was that
big and that long and you know muscular
and quite that specimen he was truly a
special special player on the way and
this is where i saw him that was in new
england right there he was on his way to
superstardom he really was and yeah he
he'd obviously hit some some you know
bumps in the road definitely but mike
yeah dallas needs him and you know
specifically mike nolan it's a scheme
change this year so they're they're
approaching i think the way they play
defense and collect their personnel a
little differently than years past you
know mike nolan has some 3-4
history in his in his defensive uh you
know playbook so i would think he wants
those gerald mccoy dante duntery po type
guys but nonetheless other than dexter
lawrence
there's no other guy that's kind of a
proven commodity as a pass rusher on the
cowboys roster and that's where gregory
and all dismiss demarcus lawrence sorry
i said dexter didn't i yes demarcus
other than that that's it
there's that that stat we just showed
and a half sacks i did the math real
quickly there's a chance it's wrong but
i do believe 14 and 19.5 together is 33
and a half 32 games not too shabby for
alden smith to the start of his career
so reason for hope for the dallas
cowboys they've got alden smith back
conditionally technically but look he's
it's always conditional when a guy has
been
suspended for more than a year and he's
in reins and then has been reinstated
they're hoping that they get randy
gregory back i've looked into josh
gordon's status because that's the guy
that the fans get most excited about
because
of fantasy football i mean let's face it
he's a guy who actually gets the
football in his hands on a regular basis
and he was phenomenal he had more
receiving yards in one season then
terrell owens and randy moss had in
their best seasons in their hall of fame
careers that's how good josh gordon can
be trying to figure out his status agent
referring to the lawyer lawyer ghosted
me thanks for nothing we'll keep on that
and see whether or not there's anything
percolating with josh gordon lawyer
ghost and lawyer i love it bam yeah
well i'm used to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports